-Performing
"Biggest, Greatest Thing"
and the title track
from his new album, "Legacy" --
number one, by the way.
No big deal --
please welcome Adam Blackstone,
with Mary Mary, Inayah,
and The Roots!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Our house this year ♪
-♪ It's gon' be right here ♪
-♪ You bring dessert -- ♪
[ Static ]
-♪ So I'm ♪
-♪ Feeling sure ♪
♪ Feeling clear,
feeling positive ♪
[ Static ]
♪♪
-What's up, New York?
What's up, New York?
♪♪
I brought my friends along.
Mary Mary.
-♪ Some people believe
that the sky is ♪
♪ The highest thing in life ♪
♪ But I believe it's just
the highest thing they've seen ♪
♪ Well, you better believe
there's someone ♪
♪ Beyond that big blue thing ♪
♪ And he's the biggest,
greatest thing ♪
♪ Biggest, greatest thing
I've never seen ♪
♪♪
♪ Now it's been said
there's nothing deeper ♪
♪ Than the ocean's deep ♪
♪ But could it be
that's just too far ♪
♪ For the human mind to think ♪
♪ But I know someone
more intelligent ♪
♪ Than words can speak ♪
♪ And he's the biggest,
greatest thing ♪
♪ The biggest greatest thing
I've never seen ♪
-Whoo!
Y'all having a good time?
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Take it to the shot.
-♪ The moral of the story is ♪
♪ That there's someone
that's definitely ♪
♪ Bigger, greater than
your mind could think ♪
♪ I know that
you were wondering ♪
♪ If everything we're saying
here is make-believe ♪
♪ But it's reality ♪
♪ And if you look around ♪
♪ He's everywhere to be found ♪
♪ 'Cause he's the biggest,
greatest thing ♪
-♪ Biggest, greatest thing
I've never ♪
-♪ I know one day ♪
-♪ Oh ♪
-♪ I'll see his face ♪
-♪ Oh, oh ♪
-♪ Man, I can't wait ♪
♪♪
-♪ Said I know ♪
-♪ I know one day ♪
-♪ I know ♪
-♪ I'll see his face ♪
-♪ Oh, oh ♪
-♪ Man, I can't wait ♪
♪♪
-Whoo!
-Hoo!
-I can't come to New York
without Questlove on the drums,
like, unh,
Questlove on the drums.
We talkin' legacy, right?
Let's go!
♪♪
-Yeah.
-Black Thought.
-Hey, yo.
♪ America could not pimp me ♪
♪ The promises I made
were not empty ♪
♪ Even if the whole world
was turned against me ♪
♪ I'd stand for
what I stand for ♪
♪ Let em' hit me ♪
♪ To spite me, they tell you
why they don't like me ♪
♪ Probably wish a bolt of
lightning to come strike me ♪
♪ They want the history books
to unwrite me ♪
♪ But didn't know for me
to be shook was unlikely ♪
♪ Look, see, it's about
the finish and not the image ♪
♪ When a legacy without
a blemish is documented ♪
♪ You can't fake it to make it,
you got to live it ♪
♪ So if I can give 100 percent,
I got to give it ♪
♪ I'm a Blackstone Ghetto
University alum ♪
♪ You mighta heard of me,
I'm a fraternity of one ♪
♪ I had to open my eyes
to see the sun ♪
♪ Now a king among men
I have finally become ♪
♪ Listen ♪
♪ That's legacy, oh, legacy ♪
♪ My reputation precedes me
like a pedigree ♪
♪ They try to discredit me,
mis-edit me ♪
♪ I risk everything
to uplift the rich legacy ♪
-♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
-Inayah!
-♪ Look at what
we have here now ♪
♪ Who knew life could be bigger
than it is right now ♪
♪ It's easy to be a tramp
but I'd rather be an imprint ♪
♪ I ain't doing nothing just
to go viral on the Internet ♪
♪ Purpose is bigger
than distraction, my dear ♪
♪ That passion better
outweigh those fears ♪
♪ When it's divine, it's not
more than you can handle ♪
♪ This is what I'm doing,
I'm just leading by example ♪
♪ Now I'm seeing all my dreams
and how they unfold ♪
♪ Still banging Stevie Wonder
loud in my headphones ♪
♪ If you ain't
trying to be a mogul ♪
♪ You can go back home ♪
♪ Man, to hell
with being temporary ♪
♪ I'd rather be legendary ♪
♪ Like all the greats
before me ♪
♪ That paved the way
just for me ♪
♪ Now I'll be legendary ♪
♪ Living my legacy ♪
♪ Legacy, oh, legacy ♪
Hey!
♪ Oh ♪
♪ Legacy, oh, legacy ♪
-♪ Raising up the sons and my
daughters to be a better me ♪
♪ Let's go ♪
Whoo!
♪ Legacy, oh, legacy ♪
You sayin' what?!
-♪ Oh ♪
-♪ Legacy, oh, legacy ♪
-♪ Raise my voice up, hoping
that they remember me ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]